as backlash mouse over president biden's
workplace vaccine mandate the labor
department admits it's going to need
lots of help to enforce it
where we target our our focus and our
effort are on those workplaces where
workers
need assistance to have a safe and
helpful workplace that typically comes
through the in the form of a complaint
the administration relying on
whistleblowers to report companies
violating the mandate this as a group of
trucking and food and retail unions are
now suing over biden's order calling it
a quote clear administrative overreach
fox and friends weekend co-host pete
hexset joins us here with reaction pete
good morning so because they don't have
enough inspectors uh to patrol
big business it sounds like uh the
government wants people to squeal on the
people they work with or tattle and a
study says
a study says over half of employees
would report a worker so in the words of
karma harris that is the plan to do it
the plan
what a great plan uh
you are gonna have you're right inside
the workforce snitches and now the
businesses are having gonna have to be
enforcers uh all the while growing
government now osha is going to become
this massive it already does provide
fines i get it but nothing along this
scale where if you're you're using
personal private health information that
companies are now forced to collect and
force onto their employees and then you
call the government to enforce it if one
person decides it's not being enforced
properly remember ronald reagan's phrase
i'm from the government that this the
scariest words in the english language
i'm from the government i'm here to help
uh this is no i'm from the government
i'm here to shut you down i'm here to
tell you how to live and that's why it's
never been more important where you live
you know my wife and i are here in sioux
falls south dakota we were here with
governor gnome last night for a law
enforcement appreciation dinner it was
amazing 2 000 cops it was it was it was
fantastic those people are grateful to
live in south dakota because they made a
choice to be there because they know
they'll be protected or at least they'll
fight back against draconian stuff like
this from the federal government where
you live medals more than ever and i
think these lawsuits have real merit i
there's no way this is constitutional to
force people to take a vaccine when they
could prove they already had coveted or
or they want a religious exemption this
is going to pit americans against each
other force employers um to enforce it
and what's so magic about 100 who made
that number up why not 98 why not 102.
it's it's all arbitrary just like six
feet apart from the beginning and
everything else people aren't buying it
and you've got to fight back against it
you absolutely don't have to apply yeah
they have plans to go after small
business too if the judge didn't stay
this order osha would have been uh well
into their taking their own action pete
what's your veterans day message i know
you're not
traditionally a veteran because you're
still in the guard but what is your
message out there for today
you know um it's it's a different one
right guys i mean it's after what
happened in afghanistan and first of all
to everybody out there that has worn the
uniform thank you i am grateful we stand
on the shoulders of previous generations
who fought wars we can't imagine
accomplish things we never could have uh
and and we are beyond grateful and don't
think for one moment to afghanistan
veterans to iraq veterans that what you
did was in vain it was not you fought
and won every single engagement every
single battle you fought so the
politicians messed it up so the generals
messed it up and i had that same gut
reaction with what happened in
afghanistan but stand tall for what you
did remember this is the greatest
country on earth and we have the best
war fighters on earth and i i salute
them and i thank them today and i'm
honored to to be able to give voice to
what they represent uh happy veterans
day everybody god bless you and thank
you for everything you've done
modern warriors pete show we were
soldiers airs this sunday on the fox
news channel at 10 pm eastern and it's
also now on fox nation pete thank you
very much for joining us from sioux
falls where i don't know the name of
that hotel but they've got fireplaces
and it looks like a great fireplace yeah
it is anna jacuzzi awesome
jacuzzi hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now